conçus par des hommes, pour des hommes
et nous préférerions remodeler le futur selon nos propres termes.
Je crois --
(Applaudissements)
Je crois que nous avons besoin d'une révolution politique des femmes
pour une égalité complète
transcendant la race, la classe, l'identité de genre,
l'orientation sexuelle
et, oui, les étiquettes politiques
car je crois que ce qui nous unit en tant que femmes
est bien plus profond que ce qui nous sépare.
Alors j'ai réfléchi
à comment fonder cette révolution politique des femmes
et c'est de cela dont je veux vous parler aujourd'hui.
(Acclamations)
(Applaudissements)
La bonne nouvelle, c'est qu'une chose qui n'a pas changé au cours du siècle
est la résilience des femmes
et notre engagement à créer une meilleure vie non seulement pour nous,
mais pour les générations à venir,
car je ne peux pas penser à une seule femme
voulant que sa fille
ait moins de droits et d'opportunités qu'elle.
Nous nous tenons sur les épaules des femmes venues avant nous
et moi,
je viens d'une longue lignée de femmes texanes coriaces.
(Acclamations)
Mes grands-parents vivaient à côté de Waco, au Texas,
dans la campagne.
Quand ma grand-mère est tombée enceinte,
elle n'allait bien sûr pas aller à l'hôpital pour accoucher,
elle allait avoir ce bébé à la maison.
Quand elle a eu des contractions,
elle a appelé la voisine pour préparer le dîner pour mon grand-père
car...
il était impensable qu'il se prépare le souper lui-même.
(Rires)
J'ai connu ça.
La voisine n'avait jamais tué de poulet
et c'est ce qui était prévu pour dîner ce soir-là.
L'histoire raconte
que ma grand-mère, sur le lit, avec des contractions,
s'est hissée sur un coude et a tordu le cou de ce poulet.
C'est ainsi que ma mère est venue au monde.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Ce qui est extraordinaire, c'est que,
même si la grand-mère de ma mère ne pouvait pas voter au Texas
car, conformément à la loi texane,
« les idiots, les imbéciles, les fous et les femmes »
n'avaient pas le droit de vote.
Juste deux générations plus tard,
ma mère, Ann Richards, a été élue la première femme gouverneure
de l’État du Texas.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
Mais vous voyez, quand maman s'est présentée au Texas,
il n'y avait pas beaucoup d'opportunités pour les femmes
et elle a passé sa vie entière à essayer de changer cela.
Elle disait :
« En tant que femmes, si vous nous donnez une chance, nous pouvons réussir.
Après tout, Ginger Rogers a fait tout ce que Fred Astaire faisait
mais elle l'a fait à reculons et en talons hauts. »
N'est-ce pas ?
Honnêtement, c'est ce que les femmes ont fait au cours du siècle dernier :
malgré le fait que nous ayons très, très peu de pouvoir politique,
nous avons fait d'énormes progrès.
Aujourd'hui aux États-Unis,
100 ans après avoir obtenu le droit de vote,
les femmes sont près de la moitié de la force de travail.
Et dans 40% des familles avec des enfants,
les femmes sont la source de revenus principale.
Les économistes estiment
que si toutes les femmes payées s'absentaient une journée du travail,
cela coûterait aux États-Unis 21 milliards de dollars
de produit intérieur brut.
En grande partie grâce au Titre IX, exigeant l'équité en matière d'éducation,
les femmes représentent la moitié des étudiants universitaires américains.
Nous sommes la moitié des étudiants en médecine, en droit --
Exactement.
(Applaudissements)
Un fait que j'adore :
récemment, l'une des classes d'astronautes diplômés de la NASA était...
Quoi ?
Pour la première fois, 50% de femmes.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
Le fait est que les femmes changent vraiment les industries,
elles changent les entreprises de l'intérieur.
Mais quand il s'agit du gouvernement, c'est une autre histoire
et je crois qu'une image vaut mille mots.
Voici une photographie de 2017 à la Maison-Blanche
alors que les dirigeants du Congrès ont été appelés pour finaliser
le projet de réforme des soins de santé présenté au Congrès.
Un des résultats de cette réunion
était de se débarrasser des prestations de maternité,
ce qui n'est pas si surprenant
puisque personne à cette table n'aurait besoin de prestations de maternité.
Malheureusement, nous l'avons appris à nos dépens
pour les femmes aux États-Unis.
Si vous n'êtes pas autour de la table, vous êtes sur le menu.
Nous ne sommes pas autour d'assez de tables
car si les femmes sont la grande majorité des votants
aux États-Unis,
nous sommes loin derrière le reste du monde
en termes de représentation politique.
Une recherche récente montre que, dans un classement de tous les pays,
les États-Unis sont 104èmes
en termes de représentation des femmes dans la vie publique.
104èmes...
Juste après l'Indonésie.
Dans ce cas, est-ce surprenant,
en considérant qui prend les décisions,
que nous soyons le seul pays développé sans congé parental payé ?
Malgré toute la recherche et les progrès réalisés
dans le suivi médical --
cela m'horrifie --
les États-Unis sont en tête
des taux de mortalité maternelle du monde développé.
Quand il s'agit de parité salariale, nous ne faisons pas beaucoup mieux.
Actuellement et en moyenne aux États-Unis,
les femmes ne gagnent que 80 centimes du dollar que gagne un homme.
Si vous êtes une femme afro-américaine,
ce ne sont que 63 centimes par dollar.
Et si vous êtes une Latina, ce ne sont que 54 centimes par dollar.
C'est un scandale.
Les femmes au Royaume-Uni
ont mis en place quelque chose que j'ai trouvé ingénieux
pour illustrer l'incidence de l'inégalité salariale.
A partir du 10 novembre et jusqu'à la fin de l'année,
elles avaient une réponse automatique sur leur boîte mail
pour indiquer toutes les semaines où elles travaillaient sans salaire.
N'est-ce pas ?
Je pense que c'est une idée qui pourrait devenir populaire.
Mais imaginez si les femmes avaient du pouvoir politique.
Imaginez si nous étions autour de la table et prenions des décisions.
Imaginez si nous avions notre parti politique de femmes
qui, au lieu d'écarter nos problèmes tels des distractions,
en faisait une priorité absolue.
Nous savons --
d'après la recherche, les femmes dans la vie publique
agissent différemment des hommes.
Elles collaborent plus avec leurs collègues,
elles transcendent les partis
et ont beaucoup plus de chances de soutenir une législation
qui améliore l'accès aux soins de santé, à l'éducation, aux droits civils.
Ce que nous nous avons observé au Congrès américain,
c'est que les femmes parrainent plus de lois
et co-parrainent plus de lois.
Toutes les preuves indiquent
que quand les femmes ont l'opportunité de servir,
elles font une énorme différence et accomplissent le travail.
A quoi ressembleraient les États-Unis
si différentes personnes prenaient les décisions ?
Je suis convaincue que si la moitié du Congrès pouvait tomber enceinte,
nous ne nous battrions plus au sujet de la contraception
et du planning familial.
(Applaudissements, acclamations)
Ce serait terminé.
(Applaudissements)
Je crois aussi vraiment que, enfin,
les entreprises arrêteraient de traiter la grossesse comme une nuisance
et comprendrait que c'est une question de santé primordiale
pour des millions de travailleurs américains.
Avec plus de femmes dans la fonction publique,
notre gouvernement prioriserait le fait de conserver l'union des familles
plutôt que de les séparer.
(Applaudissements)
Peut-être plus important encore,
toutes ces questions ne seraient plus considérées
comme « des questions de femmes ».
Ce seraient des questions fondamentales d'équité et d'égalité
derrière lesquelles tout le monde peut se rallier.
Je pense que la question est :
que faudrait-il pour fonder cette révolution politique des femmes ?
La bonne nouvelle, c'est qu'elle a déjà commencé.
Car les femmes à travers le monde exigent un lieu de travail,
elles exigent des institutions éducatives,
elles exigent des gouvernements
où le sexisme, le harcèlement sexuel et les agressions sexuelles
ne sont ni acceptés ni tolérés.
Les femmes à travers le monde
lèvent la main et disent : « Me Too », ou « Moi aussi »,
et c'est un mouvement rendu tellement plus fort
par le fait que les femmes fassent front commun dans toutes les industries,
des employées de maison aux célébrités hollywoodiennes.
Les femmes manifestent, font des sit-in,
elles s'expriment.
Les femmes remettent en question le statu quo,
nous faisons éclater les vieux tabous
et oui, nous sommes fières de faire du bruit.
Les femmes en Arabie Saoudite conduisent pour la première fois.
(Applaudissements)
Les femmes en Irak sont solidaires avec les survivants de la traite humaine.
Les femmes du Salvador à l'Irlande se battent pour les droits génésiques.
Les femmes en Birmanie font valoir les droits de l'Homme.
En bref, je pense que le leadership le plus profond du monde
ne vient pas du gouvernement.
Il est populaire, il vient des femmes à travers le monde.
(Applaudissements)
Ici aux États-Unis, les femmes s'enflamment.
Un récent sondage de Kaiser a montré
que depuis la dernière élection présidentielle en 2016,
un Américain sur cinq avait pris part à une marche ou une manifestation
et la question principale a été le droit des femmes.
Les femmes lancent de nouvelles organisations,
sont bénévoles dans des campagnes
et s'attellent à tous les sujets
de la réforme sur la sécurité des armes à feu à l'éducation publique.
Un nombre record de femmes se présentent aux élections
et elles gagnent.
Alors -- (Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Des femmes comme Lucy McBath en Géorgie.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
Lucy a perdu son fils face à la violence armée
et c'est à cause de son expérience avec le système judiciaire
qu'elle a réalisé à quel point il était déficient
et qu'elle a décidé d'y faire quelque chose.
Elle s'est présentée aux élections
et en janvier, elle ira au Congrès.
D'accord ?
(Applaudissements)
Angie Craig du Minnesota.
(Acclamations)
Son représentant au Congrès avait fait des commentaires si haineux
sur la communauté LGBTQ
qu'elle a décidé de le défier.
Et vous savez quoi ? Elle l'a fait et elle a gagné.
Quand elle ira au Congrès en janvier,
elle sera la première mère lesbienne à servir à la Chambre des représentants.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
Ou --
(Applaudissements)
Ou Lauren Underwood d'Illinois.
C'est une infirmière diplômée
et elle voit tous les jours les effets qu'a un manque d'accès aux soins de santé
sur la communauté dans laquelle elle vit
alors elle s'est présentée aux élections.
Elle a affronté six hommes durant la primaire et les a tous battus,
elle a gagné les élections
et quand elle ira au Congrès en janvier,
elle sera la première femme afro-américaine
à servir dans le district de Washington.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
Les femmes reconnaissent --
c'est notre moment.
N'attendez pas la permission,
n'attendez pas votre tour.
Comme l'a dit l'extraordinaire et feue Shirley Chisholm --
Shirley Chisholm, la première femme afro-américaine
a avoir été au Congrès
et la première candidate à la présidence pour le parti démocrate --
Shirley Chisholm a dit :
« S'il n'y a pas de place pour vous à table, sortez une chaire pliable ».
C'est ce que les femmes font à travers le pays.
Je crois que les femmes sont la force politique la plus importante et puissante
du monde,
mais comment s'assurer que ce ne soit pas qu'un moment ?
Nous avons besoin d'un mouvement mondial pour la pleine égalité des femmes
embrassant l’intersectionnalité et soit intergénérationnel,
où personne n'est laissé pour compte.
J'ai quelques idées quant à comment nous pouvons faire cela.
Un : résister ne suffit pas.
Dire contre quoi nous sommes ne suffit pas.
Il est temps d'être bruyantes et fières au sujet de ce que nous soutenons
car être pour la totale égalité est une valeur conventionnelle
et nous pouvons nous rallier derrière cela.
Car les hommes soutiennent un salaire égal pour les femmes.
Les millénials soutiennent l'égalité des sexes.
Les entreprises adoptent de plus en plus
des politiques favorables à la vie de famille,
parce que c'est ce qu'il faut faire
mais car c'est bon pour leurs salariés.
C'est bon pour les affaires.
Deux :
nous devons nous rappeler, comme l'a dit Fannie Lou Hamer,
que « personne n'est libre jusqu'à ce que tout le monde soit libre ».
Comme je l'ai dit plus tôt,
les femmes de couleur dans ce pays n'ont eu le droit de vote
que bien plus tard que les autres.
Mais depuis, elles représentent les électeurs les plus fiables
et elles sont les électeurs les plus sûrs pour les candidats
soutenant les droits des femmes.
Nous devons suivre leur exemple --
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
Car leurs problèmes sont nos problèmes.
En tant que femmes blanches, nous devons faire plus
car le racisme, le sexisme et l'homophobie
sont des problèmes qui nous touchent toutes.
Trois : nous devons voter à chaque élection.
Chaque élection.
Nous devons faciliter le processus de vote
et nous assurer que chaque vote soit compté.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
Car les obstacles au vote qui existent aux États-Unis
se dressent face aux femmes de façon disproportionnée --
les femmes de couleur, les femmes à faible revenu,
les femmes qui travaillent et essayent d'élever une famille.
Nous devons faciliter le processus de vote pour tous
et nous pouvons commencer en faisant des élections un jour férié
aux États-Unis d'Amérique.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
Quatre : n'attendez pas les instructions.
Si vous voyez un problème devant être résolu,
c'est à vous de le résoudre.
Démarrez une nouvelle association, présentez-vous aux élections.
Ou peut-être est-ce vous défendre ou défendre vos collègues au travail.
Cela dépend de nous tous.
Cinq : investissez dans les femmes.
(Applaudissements)
Investissez dans les femmes candidates, agents du changement, dirigeantes.
Pour servir d'exemple,
durant le dernier cycle d'élections aux États-Unis,
les femmes ont donné 100 millions de dollars de plus
aux candidats et aux campagnes
qu'elles ne l'ont fait il y a deux ans
et un nombre record de femmes ont gagné.
Réfléchissez à cela.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
Je pense parfois que les défis auxquels nous faisons face
semblent accablants
et semblent presque ne jamais pouvoir être résolus,
mais je pense que les problèmes semblant les plus insolubles
sont sur lesquels il est le plus important de travailler.
Le fait qu'ils n'aient pas encore été résolus
ne veut pas dire que vous ne les résoudrez pas.
Si le travail des femmes était facile,
quelqu'un d'autre l'aurait déjà fait, non ?
(Rires)
Mais les femmes à travers le monde se mettent en mouvement
et tirent leur force et leur inspiration les unes des autres.
Elles font des choses qu'elles n'auraient jamais imaginées.
Si nous pouvions prendre le progrès réalisé
en entrant sur le marché du travail,
dans le monde des affaires,
dans le système éducatif
et le canaliser pour établir un vrai pouvoir politique,
nous allons remodeler ce siècle
car une d'entre nous peut être ignorée,
deux d'entre nous peuvent être écartées
mais ensemble, nous sommes un mouvement
et nous sommes inarrêtables.
Merci.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
(Applaudissements)